[Music]
the year is 1985
16th of february a pair of researchers
aboard a model sm-03 deep sea
submersible are descending into the
depths of the atlantic ocean hours ago
they were somewhere just off the coast
of france surrounded by blue sky the
smell of the sea and the warm embrace of
the sun but now only cold darkness
surrounds them the depth of the ocean so
vast and overwhelming even light could
not escape its grasp the two-man team
are members of mtf gamma-6 also known as
the deep feeders a special task force
that specializes in the investigation
and tracking of deep-sea or oceanic
anomalies their mission to locate and
investigate the wreckage of a world war
ii german warship known as the bismarck
thought by the general public to have
gone down in the naval battle with the
british in 1941 but the story the public
doesn't know
is the real reason the pair of
foundation members were tasked with
locating the ship's wreckage site
unfortunately for these researchers
today would be remembered for something
far worse than they had anticipated
radio transmissions recorded by the
gamma 6 duo detailed the events that
took place upon finding the bismarck
designated scp-4217
the bismarck lay at the bottom of the
ocean partially submerged in the sea
floor but to the astonishment of
researchers it appeared to be perfectly
intact with no signs of damage from its
previous naval engagements gamma 6
member charles miller comments even
after the better part of five decades
this ship is still in pristine condition
there is no water damage anywhere that i
can see even stranger no ocean sediment
has accumulated on the hull of the ship
whatsoever prompted to investigate
closer agent victor miller begins
operation of the crew's model rv1 marine
probe an unmanned robotic exploratory
drone that allows the researchers to
explore the interior of the ship's
wreckage what they found unnerved them
or better said what they didn't find
just as the outside of the vessel
appeared free of any corrosion or wear
the interior of the ship was just as
immaculate the hallways were clean the
walls adorned freshly painted signs in
still legible german even the nazi
symbols painted onto command center
still held no sign of disintegration it
was as if the ship had just come off the
assembly line but strangest of all was
the lack of skeletal remains at the time
it was sunk the original crew of the
bismarck boasted a minimum of two
thousand men where were the bodies
continuing the mission the researchers
piloted their unmanned drone down the
eerie winding corridors along several of
the inner corridors of the submerged
wreckage of scp-4217
the crew find large thick walls of what
appear to be made out of a rubber-like
substance soon they find that the large
vein-like growths extend throughout the
interior of the ship like tendrils
growing in size the closer the
exploratory drone gets to the center of
the vessel all the while a slight hum
sound is picked up by the craft's sonar
equipment echoing from the center of the
ship a rhythmic pulsing the crew decide
they need to take a sample of the
rubber-like substance back to foundation
headquarters for testing this would be a
mistake upon cutting into the thick
tentacle-like growths the researchers
noticed something that fills their
stomachs with dread whatever substance
they had cut into was now bleeding the
team hears a distant rumble growing
steadily louder suddenly the ship begins
to move shuffling sand and debris strew
along the seafloor clouding the
visibility of the ship terrified the
pair hurry to try and disconnect the
cable attaching the probe to their
submersible and evacuate the site but
it's too late a booming thud shakes the
underwater craft as a large shadow
covers the glass window of the
submersible alarm systems go off as
cracks start to appear in the glass
surface the pair attempt to pilot the
vessel up towards the surface but they
are halted by a strong force pulling
them downward just as the cracks start
to spread across the surface of the
glass a giant shadow looms over the
submersible
what is that
screams and the sound of shattering
glass can be heard on the recording as
the submersible implodes from the
pressure of the watery daps since that
unfortunate incident foundation members
have recorded multiple occurrences of
scp-4217
attacking civilian cargo ships in the
atlantic particularly off the coast of
the united kingdom and as far north as
the greenland sea given its ketter
containment classification containment
of
scp-4217 consists of constant monitoring
by foundation naval forces with the
cooperation of the british royal navy in
episodes of aggression or an agitated or
hostile state naval forces are
instructed to forcibly subdue
scp-4217 through naval engagement once
enough damage is sustained
scp-4217 enters a passive state and
resubmerges
scp-4217 is divided into two parts
scp-4217-a is the bismarck itself a
nazi-era warship outfitted with an array
of eight main guns 44 secondary
armaments and dozens of units of
anti-aircraft weaponry
scp-4217-b refers to the anomalous
cephalopod organism embedded inside the
hull of the ship
scp-4217-b has two large rectangular
pupils inside of octopod eyes that
protrude from the base of the ship as
well as 12 100 to 200 meter long
tendril-like muscular appendages that
extend outward from an opening in the
stern of the vessel
scp-4217 is deemed to be classification
risk class dangerous with reports of it
emitting a mild psionic field within a
20 kilometer radius confusing anything
within range and increasing the
likelihood of friendly fire among enemy
combatants
scp-4217-hull seems to have the ability
of inorganic regeneration as damage
incurred from enemy vessels seems to
immaculately repair over time
researchers have observed what appears
to be runes or cryptic markings on the
side of
scp-4217-a's hall it is believed these
symbols were part of the original ship's
design to bolster the vessel's defense
integrity though not immediately visible
when the vessel is taking fire the
symbols appear to glow in proportion to
the amount of damage being mitigated
among its offensive capabilities apart
from the standard armaments of a world
war ii era warship scp-42
also has specialized munitions of an
unidentifiable gas compound that is
reported to have mutagenic properties
individuals that have been exposed to
the gas compound undergo rapid
spontaneous metamorphosis at a molecular
level growing an array of evolutionary
attributes which include the
accumulation of reptile-like scales or
avian feathers in place of skin the
increase or decrease of the number of
limbs digits or even ocular olfactory or
auditory organs and in one reported case
an event where multiple members of one
crew were fused at a subatomic level
into one functioning organism the more
study into this particular incident is
needed
scp-4217 also has the ability of
subsurface oceanic mobility and can
submerge itself when not in combat with
enemy vessels underwater propulsion
appears to be generated by the ejection
of water from scp-4217-b's
cavity and reaches a top speed of
approximately 30 knots
scp-4217 undergoes cycles of passive
behavior that is periodically
interrupted by moments of hostility
towards civilian craft particularly
resurfacing and going after
transatlantic cargo vessels it is
believed this is analogous to the
history and original mission of the
bismarck operation reinenbaum during
world war ii the german luftwaffe was
besieging london in a series of nightly
air raids that would be colloquially
known as the blitz it was the grand
intention of the third reich to cut off
supplies to the british to limit the
resistance to the nazi war machine
however what pestered the nazis most and
hindered this effort was the consistent
american support provided by the u.s
government in the form of food and
supplies delivered to the british via
atlantic trade routes by cargo ship the
german bismarck and her sister ship the
tirpitz were created for the very goal
of stopping these transports of cargo to
the united kingdom as well as sinking as
many allied vessels as possible the year
is 1937 in a top secret effort to make
preparations for an approaching war
adolf hitler turns to his most trusted
expert on the supernatural chief ss
officer heinrich himmler among other
projects himmler ordered the anarbei
obscuracore a german organization tasked
with the procurement and investigation
of otherworldly or otherwise
unexplainable phenomenon to begin the
creation of two ships the bismarck and
the tirpitz the former named after the
iron chancellor otto von bismarck who in
1890 unified the german people these
vessels were to be created using
recently uncovered technological
oddities the obscure core had found in
their studies of the occult sources of
information about the exact creation of
scp-4217 are highly expunged from the
record but bits and pieces did survive
among what little the foundation was
able to collect and in the records of
the ussr after their occupation of
eastern germany following the fall of
the nazi regime during the second world
war the earliest mention of
scp-4217's conception dates back to
early 1937 when a top secret shipment of
unknown materials labeled components of
thematological constructs is intercepted
by a foundation agent working undercover
in a german shipment center outside of
hamburg the foundation agent marcus
straub is instructed to maintain
surveillance on the shipment in 1939
upon near completion of the soon-to-be
christened bismarck a second shipment
labeled with the insignia of the obscure
corps is intercepted by the foundation
agent only this shipment appears unlike
any other reports of the massive
shipping container holding machinery
capable of aquatic life support indicate
organic living cargo though the
foundation agent was unable to identify
the exact nature of the contents of the
shipment straub reported hearing sounds
emanating from the cargo hold sounds
similar to that of a heartbeat just a
year later the bismarck is seen making
its first naval trial run when it
experiences a massive electrical
discharge just offshore shutting the
vessel down momentarily until power was
restored shortly after reports show
luminescent symbols briefly visible on
the hull of the ship thamatological
symbols for the laymen are symbols that
embodied the study of miracles because
of this it was apparent to the
foundation that some occult anomaly was
responsible for the strange
characteristics of the german vessel and
an order for termination was reached by
the o5 council the hunt for scp-4217
in the autumn of 1940 under orders of
neutralization of scp-4217
all active foundation agents presiding
in germany were ordered to converge on
the site of the bismarck to stop the
completion of the vessel but when the
time came for the operation every single
one of the foundation agents vanished no
records of what happened were ever found
no clothing notes not even a trace of
their existence was left behind the
mission was deemed a failure and
subsequent attempts to neutralize
scp-4217 became far more difficult after
the bismarck received a full crew of
semen the fully manned and well-equipped
scp-4217 became a menace to both
military and civilian craft on the high
seas of the atlantic at times appearing
without warning seemingly out of thin
air
scp-4217 psionic field obscured it from
the new technological advancements in
enemy radar systems the us government
had in development the ship became a
shadow on the atlantic a subject of
ghost stories for anyone daring to
assist the british government with the
war effort furthermore
scp-4217 did not seem to be content with
the surrender of enemy vessels captured
enemy ships were gassed turning the men
into manufactured beasts and then
sinking the enemy vessels to the depths
of the ocean even submarines were no
match on one report describing an
attempt to elude the vessel by diving
below the surface only to be entangled
by enormous squid-like appendages that
dragged the craft back up to the surface
before crushing it in its grasp fearing
the safety of the public the o5 council
decided they could not stand by and let
more innocent lives be taken they voted
to supersede the foundation's policy on
absolute secrecy to notify the british
government of the danger
scp-4217 posed to maritime civilians
with cooperation from the british royal
navy foundation representatives joined
the crew of hms hood and hms prince of
wales to track reports of the bismarck
being sighted off the coast of
scandinavia in what history books would
come to know as the battle of denmark
strait hms hood and hms prince of wales
engaged scp-4217
and a secondary german warship known as
the prinz yojin confused by the ship's
psionic field the british naval ships
experienced trouble identifying the
bismarck and engage in friendly fire
before being able to regain control of
their armaments concentrating all volley
of fire on scp-4217
the attack proves futile as after the
embers and smoke of munitions fire wear
off the sides of the bismarck's hull
appear to vibrate with glowing energy
mangled metal begins to straighten back
into perfect frame breeches and armor
begin to heal before the soldier's very
eyes and all that is left as evidence
the ship had ever taken fire is a cloud
of steam emanating from the hull of
scp-4217
the water surrounding the vessel begin
to boil as underwater tentacles lurch
out and capture the hms hood dragging
her majesty's ship forward the men
aboard frantically try to regain control
but seconds later are met with another
crisis a salvo of artillery shells fired
from
scp-4217's guns hit the ship severing
lines and damaging railguns as a
mutagenic gas compound starts to spread
among the royal seamen in mere minutes
the majority of the crew are engulfed in
toxic fumes and experience vomiting and
convulsions their bodies undergoing
rapid involuntary mutagenesis including
the growth of limbs the development of
fur feathers and scales and one report
it was said that multiple victims even
fused together to create one single
horrifying entity those exposed to the
gaseous compound were designated
scp-4217-1 the captain of the hms hood
barricades himself inside the helm but
the resulting instances of scp-4217-1
overpower the ship and neutralize
command in the seconds that follow any
witness of the horror that the men
aboard the hms hood experienced is
forever entombed in the watery grave of
the british vessel as the ship is sunk
by a volley of munitions fire from the
combined might of the german fleet some
men attempting to jump overboard and
swim to safety are dragged down by their
legs by the mutated instances of
scp-4217 and pulled under lungs filling
with seawater as they scream until their
breath is no more in disbelief the crew
of hms prince of wales decides to
retreat in the days that followed at the
bequest of foundation members the
british royal navy launches a full-scale
armada to hunt down and neutralize the
bismarck though
scp-4217 sustained little damage in the
previous encounter the ship began
leaking a black oil-like substance
thought by scp researchers to be an
organic waste product of scp-4217-b
the allied naval forces are able to
follow the trail to the coast of france
where under the lead of hms king george
v british warships surround the german
vessel and opened fire this time they
were ready with approval from the o5
council foundation members provide the
british forces with enhanced munitions
and armament capable of overwhelming
scp-4217's thematological defenses on
the eve of battle it appears to the
allied forces that the psionic field
generated by scp-4217
is too great as the naval company find
it difficult to land targeted assaults
on the german vessel after losing
several smaller vessels to the colossal
appendages of scp-4217
foundation members on board authorized
the use of a redacted scp it is brought
in to deactivate
scp-4217 psionic field the tide of the
battle turns and after a fierce battle
scp-4217 becomes immobile and unable to
return fire relentless the british
continue their bombardment until the
artillery munitions on the ship explode
into a giant fireball flooding the
ship's compartments with the noxious
fumes of the mutagenic compound its crew
members either jump overboard or are
engulfed in the cloud of gas the british
vessels capture any survivors and watch
as
scp-4217 slowly sinks below the waves
down to the depths of the ocean where it
would lay dormant for the next 48 years
scp-4217's 121 surviving crew members
were captured and interrogated most of
the low-ranking german soldiers were
released to british custody 109 of them
having their memory wiped by foundation
staff 12 remaining members of the crew
were sent to site-23 for further
detention and advanced interrogation and
74 of the instances of scp-4217-1
the mutated subjects were recovered and
sent to site-23 for further observation
it was thought that on that day
scp-4217 was deemed neutralized and no
longer a matter of priority the bismarck
sunk into memory and myth it was only
until the recent resurgence of scp-42
that the foundation saw the need to
collect as much information on the
organism inhabiting scp-4217-a
as possible decades-old manuscripts and
ledgers were pulled from hundreds of
viable sources from the intelligence
then gathered foundation members have
come to the hypothesis that the entity
powering the vessel known as the
bismarck has what is believed to be
extraplanetary origin world war ii era
documents uncovered between commander
carl reuter of the german obscure corps
and a dr hans meyer indicated discovery
of an organic life form of unknown
origin found in a crashed aircraft near
feldberg park in the black forest
mountain range in germany further
correspondence with obscure corps
members otto schmidt and dietrich
klosner indicate that researchers were
conducting trials on the creature's
ability to create psionic fields and to
control or confuse enemy subjects within
its range with a letter from dietrich
klostner suggesting the creature could
be used as a power source for an
unspecified engine further evidence of
scp-4217-b's extraplanetary origin can
be found in a 1993 incident between
foundation naval ship scps nemed and
scp-4217
this is the only incident on record
where contact was established with the
creature classified as
scp-4217-b on july 22nd
scp-4217 had reappeared off the coast of
britain anticipating hostility scp-s
nemed scps cesaire and scps parthelon
were instructed to close in on
scp-4217's location with orders to
subdue the vessel if necessary however
on this occasion
scp-4217 did not appear to be after any
vessel it was simply drifting along at
sea no propulsion engines active
noticing the change in
scp-4217's behavior captain kurt wegner
decided to withhold military engagement
and investigate
scp-4217's behavior sailing within 200
meters of the bismarck the scps nemet
attempted radio contact with the german
vessel after repeated attempts at
communication the crew were met with
only silence and static chatter giving
up captain wagner puts down the radio
receiver when suddenly the sound of
music is heard playing over the speakers
of a ship the tune is the national
anthem of nazi germany the captain hails
the vessel again repeating his attempts
at communication do you do you
understand me at first only static can
be heard then came a reply
[Music]
the ominous voice could be heard from
the speakers the captain hesitated for a
moment members of the crew looking at
each other with apprehension the captain
replied confirming themselves as a ship
and then asking if
scp-4217 knew what it was and where it
came from what followed was the crew of
the scps nemed receiving a video feed
from scp-4217
featuring a high volume of images in
rapid succession among them were images
of german cities adolf hitler's telecast
of the 1936 olympics an unknown
structure in outer space and an
increasing repetition images of the
planet jupiter particularly the giant
storm on jupiter known to the public as
the great red spot or scp-2399
as foundation members know it the
transcript of the radio communication
between captain wagner and
scp-2417 stops when the video feed
begins to focus heavily on images of
jupiter
scp-4217's responses become more erratic
and agitated as it repeats the words
storm cloud and red the markings on its
hull beginning to light up and the
underwater shadows of its tentacles
beginning to create whirlpools of
displacement under the bow of the ship a
shrill shrieking begins to flood out of
the speakers followed by a high piercing
high-pitched beeping sound that
overloads the communication equipment
causing sparks to fly as crew members
cover their ears and hide under control
panels the scps nemet barely escapes as
scp-4217 becomes hostile using its
massive tendril-like appendages to
assail the naval combatants firing its
armament in all directions after a
fierce battle the foundation naval
forces were able to neutralize and
subdue
scp-4217 no further attempts at
communication have been recorded to keep
the veil of secrecy foundation members
constructed a replica ship to be sunk
and intentionally rediscovered by
oceanographer robert ballard in 1989.
any recent sightings of the nazi era
bismarck are flagged as
misidentification by scp staff for now
foundation members continue to monitor
the behavior of scp-4217
and protect the public from its
existence now go check out
scp-1861 the crew of the hms
wintershimer and
scp-5987 siren head for more anomalous
underwater vessels from scp explained